[Music]
who likes Borat king/queen a long time
ago whoa that's quote very nice I was
talking about this but it was uh when he
was cuz obviously have the the normal
quotes but then he was trying to marry
Pamela Anderson and then he was like oh
will you marry me and she was no he goes
agreement not necessary that's what I
was like I was like this is so [ __ ] up
what's so funny that way Larry like
screaming in my room my favorite cool
frame is like her regime is like sleeve
of wizard you're like yeah my wife she
used to be tight and then when she got
older at the age of 14 it started I feel
like you're like 10 years later when she
was 14 I was like oh [ __ ] movie or the
the rvg show where he was like showing
like pictures of like this girl on him
it was like straddling him in the
reverse cowgirl and then I he was like
this is my sister
that's my show I was in the movie is it
from the movie where he goes this is my
sister number 4 prostitute yeah yeah
yeah yes the movie and then they're like
in a village like some country in
Eastern Europe and [ __ ] yeah okay okay
so not boring I was like Borat is making
every appearance that would be [ __ ]
dope if the actual feedback is poor at
the sasha is coming back what he has
made an appearance at a far right wing
March do you remember this is America
that was yeah that was [ __ ] genotype
evacuation is that he's gearing up for
season 2 I have it's a long video so I'm
trying to cut it up but here's a little
snippet of what he's working on he's one
of my favorite [ __ ] people
yeah brighten it how to do this alright
here we go
listen to you know we're all singing a
bluegrass song and
the lyrics are very very profound okay
Obama we're gonna inject Hillary Clinton
what you're gonna do we're gonna put her
in jail ever used to do
WH o what
so he beat this left one was tryna we're
gonna do come like World War two
obviously it was Japan that God knew
yeah China PNTR wrong on purpose like
that's why he's so genius cuz he knows
like the stereotype of these ignorant
folks where you don't tell the
difference well you didn't say that he
said uh are you saying okay that gets me
yeah yeah so you says Chinese people
what we're gonna do we're gonna loot
Newcomb like its World War two right
that's this is the [ __ ] genius behind
his comedy is because he's doing a
reverse where this is how these he knows
that like their child agents are Chinese
all Asians are the same right so they
don't even know the difference that it
was Japan that got a new that's true
China was on the side of America
during World War two so then because of
that [ __ ] he knows the history and
everything right he plays into it and he
[ __ ] shows how ignorant they are and
I'm like they're singing along I know
genius like a part of those like it cuz
it starts off easier and lighter and
then like as it goes like the stuff that
he's saying gets worse and worse yeah
they get more excited like this cuz
they're like I feel like you see people
start singing some more people start
singing along and then he says something
and I think you could tell like then it
goes to half the people singing along
because there's other half they're like
okay this might be a little too much I'm
not this racist but like I was like that
I was cool with like the border I'm high
racist but now it's just crazy you talk
about chopping up people it's like what
the [ __ ] but yes he added there's more
to of the like he does liberals he like
shouts out like everything that is
leftist he's like throwing into this
song and trying to get right-wing people
to basically chant we want to chop
everyone up or we want to injecting the
flew this pretty nuts it's pretty nuts
and then people are falling for it like
they're doing it and then so the story
is he he got on stage and with them came
a lot of security guys and so whenever
people realized he was seeing some
[ __ ] like that
a lot of the event event organizers who
are trying to like get on stage to pull
a muscle
but his security guys stopped in bed
people from even doing anything
so he rant like this video clip was
eight minutes and chanting this [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] necessary I saw like behind
the scenes videos where other pure
posting where there was like the event
corner is filming it being like they're
trying to shut it down
because they knew what was going on
there buddy was smarter but then there
was other people being interviewed in
the crowd and they were like this is
dope they like this give him two options
and they cheered louder for their more
intense yeah so then afterwards once the
the event security was able to past
shasha's security they jumped off stage
and they ran to an ambulance that was
already set they're parked there and
though that was their getaway vehicle
like your Sasha like you don't get away
what do you mean like he ran off right
but like you don't really get away
because you're famous and they know it
no matter what it's like he's gonna
release the video it's like at that
point people didn't know it was him and
that's all that matters I think all you
kids buds not being physically
apprehended I see you didn't even go
anywhere he wants yes yeah and then he's
made another the costume that he had on
his [ __ ] oh he's got a good big nose
and I liked all the facial hair stuff I
mean no one who could really recognize
him in the moment but then you kind of
like I think back what the [ __ ] was that
that looks like he plays the bottle like
it in his Hill home and [ __ ] like who
and he has a [ __ ] dog that just
chills next to him and [ __ ] so all the
videos are going viral where people
posted I guess but then other people
took down were like hey is this Sasha
bear corn
everyone was like I think it is so it
wasn't like they put it on people no it
was like people are recording the
audience that they this guy yeah and
then he thought he was real at first I
was really skinny nothing left got it
and all I just the regular media and was
like this is [ __ ] funny
oh so the people in the audience didn't
know was him nobody did I don't know why
they would have had it go on so no-one
watch it they don't watch Borat or know
what he does yeah
internet thing in the moment of it
you're not thinking that think yeah like
you never think that's gonna happen to
you you that's true especially if you're
like in like Indiana and you're like out
of State Fair it's like some small
little thing or whatever your you're
your own bubble yeah especially for like
a right-wing event you're like no one's
gonna try to [ __ ] with us yeah and then
how many times have you seen an actual
celebrity know anything on and you're
like wait is it and they're not even
wearing any time just true I don't even
believe that the celebrity I'm looking
at is the celebrity I think it's like
nah I look similar it's a doppelganger
yeah that's true so he's made another
appearance in New York - he somehow got
an interview with Giuliani and that
didn't go according to plan cos and he
came into the interview the way Giuliani
was explaining it was he was actually
sat in front of a lady interviewer and
they were just going through some like
he quote softball questions and they're
know where sasha comes in wearing like a
pink bikini thing and then that's when
Juliana you got up and like and he kind
of just canceled the interview and call
the police and stuff man but then
Giuliani I think he was pretty pretty
good like sport about it she was like ha
I didn't get got by Sacha Baron Cohen so
he was kind of like you know what it's
like okay I think he actually had an
encounter with Giuliani in the past did
he I think so
the previous season I don't know if it's
the same it might even be the Ali G show
yes that far back
what it's like I mean he was like the
mayor what was he doing that he would
have got him if he came out like a pink
suitor God then he's - yeah it's like
maybe that was the whole point of it he
just wanted to be like ah I'm here [ __ ]
yeah maybe absolutely the way he got rum
spilt though that [ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy
really good he got him to sign his
waterboarding kit what was the one that
he got him in the hotel room for gay sex
I don't know I like the guy where he was
able to get him to take off his pants
and he was chasing around with his butt
like oh the past the governor's good
yeah you got a strap-on on that's what
it was he was trying to chase it like I
have a homosexual and I will come and I
will have sex with you whoo you'd have
to defend yourself and you would chase
him with a dildo because he knows
they're so afraid of like the
homosexuality yeah that's all he they
have two other guys he would teach him
self-defense and then the guys would
have to bite his wiener off so if they
had to put their mouth on the dildo and
bite it off he's so smart with how he
does everything that's true yeah so like
I don't know
I love Sacha Baron Cohen I love Borat
but at the same time I'm kind of like I
don't know if this kind of material
needs to be done at this point and with
the climate that the world is in either
so I know I get part of me you like cuz
it's divisive more device it's very
divisive yeah it's very divisive and
then it's like a this is like kind of
like my logic on it it's like if you
know you have a relationship with
someone whether it's your girlfriend
wife your best friend and like your
relationship with that person isn't good
and there's like distrust which and I
use the word distrust because there's
distrust with the government there's
distrust from both sides of the
political spectrum whatnot you can't
just start joking with that person you
know you can't like if my wife doesn't
trust me I can't just start joking with
her and be like all things are good and
like how joke about some hard concepts
here you know and it's just it doesn't
work that way but if the relationship is
good right then it's like cool I
understand where you're coming from
let's have some jokes but I think where
the country is that right now I don't
think we're in a place to
I'm gonna do this bed same time I love
what I do like about his comedy though
it's you're right like they're they're
not in a good place but sometimes I
think they're also so I think when
you're talking about like what say you
and TIFF or like you're you're trying to
like trying to get common ground or
something right that means both people
are willing to work true so they're
willing to work I'm being vulnerable I
put my ego down you put your you go down
what I like about him is he's choosing
people that are stubborn and they're not
even willing to work yeah so he goes I'm
a poke I'm gonna find the irony and your
stubbornness
yeah that's sure you want to chop people
up too you want to give people that will
harmful ooh you know he's like you know
he's like you because I think what he
does is if he is able to point out the
irony Xandra stubbornness then they can
get to the phase where you know what I
was thinking kind of stupid let's start
working some [ __ ] out that's true that's
a good point yeah I would be because
it's obviously we're more just like well
whatever side you're on you but they
typically we find it funnier if they do
it on the right you know for me I'll
find it funny anyway it's funny anyway
if it's done clever but also the the
context cuz say at one of those like
marches or rallies they're not like
discussing stuff properly people are
emotions they're just loud being there
being their echo yeah okay and if you
did that on the left more usually the
more like emotional they're they're more
like talking about actual issues and if
someone came and start trying that they
would be out of place to be doing that
somewhere but if we were like just going
crazy just having a party and someone
was trolling that would annotated
properly that'd be funny - I'm not gonna
say somebody's not funny just because
it's going against the issues I'm for
right so this was [ __ ] I I feel like
on any side of would it happen but I
feel like he makes fun of super liberals
- like he had a character on this is
America that was an NPR radio non-binary
guy that lived in a yurt in like I don't
know it was so I think what he does is
he exposes
ignorance and intolerance he goes on the
other sides of the spectrum and say
who's the most radical
going on either side of the teams and
then yeah and even he even gets like
corrupt politicians and makes a [ __ ]
fool out of them and all that [ __ ] and I
love it
if you're gonna figure out laughs with
this we're gonna have to take it if it
happens - yeah that's very true I mean
like I don't I don't follow him at all
but like I what I like about like the
things I've seen it's like it's not so
much as like I'm making fun of you it's
like I'm gonna have you make fun of
yourself
yeah all right that's the main thing
[Music]